hey what's going on everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for today
june 30th 2021 that means it's my mom's
birthday happy birthday mom
i know you're having a good day i know
you got the flowers i know you're having
lunch with a friend
and i will facetime you in a little bit
for everybody else
uh don't forget to subscribe to our
youtube channel tap the notification
bell and yes yesterday in the last
couple days i've commented on how many
of you said that you didn't see the
trump video
in the feed i saw even more comments on
that yesterday of course the surefire
way to always get our videos
is to subscribe to
reubenreport.locals.com you get push
notifications we don't manipulate the
feed in any way
we got ad free stuff over there and live
video and live chat and a whole bunch of
other stuff
and today because i wanted to give my
guys an extended
uh long weekend for july 4th uh after we
take
this show we're taping our q a for
tomorrow normally we do a q a every
thursday but i'm not going to
be taping shows tomorrow and friday so
my guys can all have and myself actually
i've got some family here
uh still hanging over from my uh
birthday
party last weekend uh so that we could
all have a nice four day weekend and
celebrate america and be with family and
barbecue and do the fireworks and all
that good stuff so anyway so we are
taping
tomorrow's q a today so if you would
like to submit
a question and perhaps i will answer it
you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
submit your question right there
and we'll be taping that in about an
hour or so
we got three stories for you today we
had about five that were on the docket
that were all possibilities i said guys
let's whittle it down and that's exactly
what we've done uh first off you know
this woman
uh ilhan omar she's from the hamas
caucus that's the wing of the democratic
party
uh that doesn't like the jews well she's
like sort of the main don't like the jew
lady
and i don't like her and it has nothing
to do with her being black and it has
nothing to do with her being muslim
i just don't like her she has horrible
policies and i think she's a genuinely
bad actor in american politics and she's
making the situation our ability to talk
to each other
significantly worse so she was on jake
tapper's show
and yesterday i talked about how
nobody's really watching jake tapper
since trump is gone the tapper's numbers
have bottomed out but occasionally
sometimes something happens on this show
that does go viral
and ilhan omar was on there and jake
tapper asked her
about some of her previous anti-semitic
comments and she doubled down
yet again so we're gonna play that uh
then there was
uh a video a couple days ago one of the
white house press conferences
where jen i call her jen pasaki but my
guys keep saying dave just call her gen
saki
that's the name not sake like the
japanese drink it's gensai
i'll see what i can do on that well she
basically she's just gaslighting america
i mean her endless lies
and and conflation of issues and
confusing of things and everything else
well she basically said that it's the
republicans who wanted to fund the
police that
some would say it's the republicans who
are calling for defunding the police so
we're going to show you that video
and then we're going to show you a
compilation of democrats calling for
defunding the police because she's a
liar
and we've got to call out the liars and
then finally remember barack obama he
was the president for eight years before
the orange man
uh we played a video a couple days ago
was that last week i believe
where he's suddenly uh he's very
concerned that the republicans
are focusing on critical race theory and
that's not something we should really be
focused on we should be focused on
climate change
well now this week he's very concerned
that republicans are all suffering
from misinformation that conservative
media is confusing people places like
youtube
are making you think scary things uh
which is
sort of ironic because you know four
years of
trump's a russian asset all the other
lies brett kavanaugh's racist the
covington
kids jesse smallett blah blah blah no
problem with that kind of misinformation
but misinformation that might empower
you to think freely
and just not be a slave on the democrat
plantation he doesn't like that so we're
going to talk about all that
and before i get to it i want to talk to
you guys about bambi you know when
you're running a business hr
issues can kill you wrongful termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulations the list goes on and on
and hr managers salaries aren't cheap at
an average of
70 000 bucks a year bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e
was specifically created for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99
a month with bambi you can transform hr
from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you
manage your employees day-to-day all for
just 99
a month month a month no hidden fees
cancel any time if you're like me then i
bet you didn't start your business
because you wanted to spend all your
time on hr compliance that is absolutely
true
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today
go to bambi.com ruben right now to get
your free free hr
audit that's bambi.comruben spelled
bam to the b-e-e dot com slash reuben
and now back to me okay three stories
for you let's start with
ilhan omar so i want to be very very
very very very very
very clear about what i'm about to say
about ilhan omar i do not care that
she's black
i do not care that she's muslim
irrelevant i don't care
about immutable characteristics i don't
care about what anyone's private beliefs
are
i don't care about anyone's skin color
all of those things
irrelevant to me i care about people's
thoughts and this woman consistently
consistently spews out anti-semitic
nonsense
now you not you guys know that i don't
like accusing people of being
anti-semites
or racists or homophobes or anything
else we've we've used all of these words
unfortunately
uh in such a egregious way
that usually it means nothing usually
when someone gets called a racist on
twitter
or in mainstream media that usually
means they're not racist it means
they're just not a progressive right
they're just not
woke ilhan omar actually is
a racist she has an obsession with jews
and israel an absolute obsession there's
only one country on earth
that she wants to boycott it's the
obscenely tiny
little place that's the one little
jewish state while we've talked about
this before
there are dozens of uh muslim majority
states dozens of christian majority
states
she constantly has odd things to to say
about the jews
and she's an anti-semite it just kind of
is i don't really like saying things
like that but it just
kind of is and now she was on jake
tapper's show yesterday and he was
asking her about a bunch of
her anti-semitic statements which by the
way over the last couple years when
she's made anti-semitic statements
uh nancy pelosi has defended her one
time she said something's the effect of
well ilhan's not from here
so maybe some of it got lost in
translation some some of her english
maybe wasn't quite right i mean i think
you'll see
her english is just fine but jake
basically asks her about some of her
remarks
and then some of her jewish colleagues
in congress and just
really listen to what she says
in 2019 you said lawmakers support
israel because it's quote all about the
benjamins which implies that politicians
only support israel because of money
there was a tweet from 2012 and when you
said
israel had hypnotized the world do you
understand
why some of your fellow house democrats
especially jews
find that language anti-semitic i have
welcomed
any time you know my colleagues have
asked to have a conversation
to learn from them for them to learn
from me
i think it's really important for uh
these
members to realize that they haven't
been
partners in injustice they haven't been
um you know equally engaging uh
in seeking justice uh around the world
and i and i think
you know i will continue to to do that
it is important
for me as someone who who knows what it
feels like to experience
injustice in ways that many of my
colleagues don't
to be a voice in finding finding
accountability
asking for mechanisms for justice for
those
who are maligned oppressed and
who have had injustice um down to them
man she is just vile listening to the
double speak
and the intentional way she conflates
things so he specifically asked about
her her colleagues especially jewish
democrats
her line was these members haven't been
partners
in injustice they haven't been equally
engaging in seeking justice around the
world
so he's specifically asking about the
jews that's what she's saying now i'm
sure nancy will say well she didn't
understand the question correctly
or something like that and by the way
already on her little twitter thread
with like
one of her half-assed apologies where
she said yes jews have marched with
martin luther king
and a bunch of nonsense the apologies
are just worthless at this point right
that's just
it's just a token throwaway nothing but
what she's really saying there is
these members haven't been partners in
justice she's just trying to make
everything about israel which is exactly
what you would
would do if you were solely focused on
the jews so her answer in a certain way
is anti-semitic in that regard
she's saying they haven't been partners
in injustice they haven't been equally
engaging in seeking justice around the
world
what she's saying is i don't really like
israel they've defended israel
they are bad guys ilhan omar
is is not a good actor she is not a good
actor and i don't think she is a good
american and by american i don't mean
you have to believe everything that i
believe
but ilhan omar is an immigrant a first
generation immigrant from somalia she
came here
from somalia try to imagine ilhan omar
or rashida talib or aoc or even bernie
sanders for that matter
saying anything positive about america
or anything positive about our allies
or going out on the international stage
and and
singing the praises of america and
talking about all the wonderful things
of america
i find her to be particularly
nefarious in what she's doing because as
a first generation
immigrant you might be a little more
appreciative
of the country that let you in and
allowed you to become extraordinarily
disgustingly
powerful and influential you might be
appreciative of that
but she's not appreciative of that and i
was thinking about this and when i was
on tour with jordan peterson we went to
about 20 different countries all over
the globe
and i remember very specifically like
when i was thinking about what kind of
jokes i was going to do in the morning
and everything
like i would never go to a country and
and attack
that country like you can poke fun i
could poke fun at like the food
in england isn't the greatest food or
everyone's eating fish and chips all day
long but
like little things little cultural
things that you can make fun of but i
always wanted to be respectful of the
country that i was in i'm a guest in
that country now she's a legal citizen
here i'm not
saying that she's a guest here but as
someone that came here
that knows how good it is here that this
country has given her so much
she doesn't like this country and if you
think that i'm making that up i mean
just
watch on watch mark my words although
now that i'm saying it out loud they'll
probably do something different
but on every july 4th on every labor day
on every memorial day
every thanksgiving any day that is about
americans or defending america
or our you know honoring our freedom and
our and our emancipation all these
things
they barely ever can choke out anything
positive about america on twitter or any
messaging
that they have they usually couch it and
you know we're pretty bad but you know
we did
something anyway ilhan omar look jake
tapper you know i sort of feel bad for
jake tapper in a way because as i
referenced yesterday i think jake tapper
there is some flicker of something
decent there and he was supposed to be
the one guy at cnn
that was going to be decent and you
could just see it on his face like you
could just see the misery
and and just that he knows like what cnn
has become and
you know he knows he can't push back any
further otherwise she'll basically turn
to him and you're a jew ain't you a jew
mr cnn guy and he happens to be jewish i
don't really care about that
either um but look her obsessive
uh focus on israel her
obsessive focus on comparing the united
states
to terrorist organizations and all of
these things when she wants justice she
actually when she says justice
she means injustice and she will never
be on the side i don't think of
of anything that i think a truly free
country will be for that that's just a
that's a problem
that's a problem and unfortunately uh we
don't have democrats
who are willing to stand up and this is
obviously directly connected
to the failure of liberalism it let in
illiberalism
and now you have a democratic party
where people say like nancy pelosi
who wasn't bananas her whole career and
even a guy like joe biden wasn't bananas
i i know some people don't like when i
say that but these people were not
radical bananas lunatics
chuck schumer was not a radical banana's
lunatic but all of them have been
swayed and they've been um they've been
hypnotized i would say she said
that israel has hypnotized the world
somehow yeah uh well i would
say that the the progressive group think
the the
brain numbing nonsense that comes out of
the progressives
has basically hypnotized all of the
democrats so nobody says anything about
it so there is a privilege
you know she's always talking about
white privilege there is a privilege
in the united states of america there's
one privilege and it's democrat
privilege because if you are a democrat
you're allowed to be in blackface like
jimmy kimmel
or like ralph northam the governor of
virginia or now that there's now there's
this
senator in rhode island who goes to an
all-white
country club you probably didn't hear
that on mainstream media right
if you're a democrat you have the
privilege of you're allowed to be a
racist you're allowed to say whatever
you want about
jews or white people or christians or
anything else and you get a pass
that is the privilege that we've got in
america and ilhan omar is a walking
talking
example of democrat privilege all right
speaking of democrats and privilege
because one of those privileges is you
can say whatever you want
and the media doesn't really call you
out on it
well jen sake sake right saki not saki
saki more like saki like i'd like
another sake warm please
jen saki who is the white house white
house press secretary
um she said the other day that basically
republicans are the one trying to defund
the police this is just pure gaslighting
this is pure
nonsense this is we all know it but they
have no problem saying it and she kind
of smiles when she says it so this is
from a couple days ago and then we got a
great compilation for you here's jen
saki the thought there basically that
somebody
some criminal who has been committing
crimes with limited interruption or
interference from police for the last
couple weeks or months
is going to stop this easy life of crime
if
they have a summer job well i think the
president believes that we shouldn't and
we shouldn't allow access to guns to
those criminals who are currently
illegally biling them from some dealers
across the country and
part of his announcement is taking steps
to do exactly that but part of his
announcement
is also ensuring their specific guidance
to
communities across the country to ensure
that they have funding to get
more community police around the country
something that was supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that the other party was
for defunding the police i'll let others
say that but
man i mean sake you are disgusting
you're just a disgusting person because
if you believe that the destruction of
truth is something that you can do with
a smug smile on your face
and pretend that it's the republicans
that wanted to defund the police
you're just you're just awful like what
else how else are we supposed to analyze
these people
right like how else are we supposed to
analyze people
whose job it is to give us information
uh when they blatantly lie to us she
also before i show you this compilation
of democrats uh calling for defunding
the police not republicans
she said something to the effect of we
shouldn't allow guns to people who are
illegally getting them that's what she
said the president doesn't want
uh people who are illegally getting guns
to get guns
do you see the flaw in that statement
it's illegal already
but this is what they do with everything
we have laws that if you're a crazy
person
or a drug addict or a former felon or a
series of other things you can't get
guns and guess what you're not going to
believe this guys
people find ways around things and most
people who do mass shootings get the
guns
illegally okay we know that by the way
74 people
were shot in chicago last weekend six
fatally
uh did did that make it to the white
house press conference did that make it
to uh cnn or wapo
or new york times or anything 74
people shot and by the way i'm willing
we can
i don't know that we'll even find the
numbers on this because they probably
don't know who did the shooting
uh or at least they probably haven't
arrested anybody or very few of the
people have been arrested but i'm gonna
guess out of the 74
shot all of the guns were probably
gotten illegally it's you it's not
nra members it's not people who go about
the legal systems
that then run around start shooting
people okay it's just not we know that
it isn't there has
been no evidence ever of a mass shooting
that was done by an nra member
who got their gun legally okay so it's
just sort of double it's again it's the
double talk it's the double
speak it's this 1984 orwellian
doublespeak
very similar to the ilhan omar story
that we just covered they we the
president believes we shouldn't allow
guns to people who are illegally getting
them
yes they're illegally getting them we
already don't allow it but people find a
way
life finds away jeff goldblum jurassic
park well anyway then at the end she
says it's
some might say republicans are the ones
who wanted to defund the police okay
sake take a look i am for defunding the
police
yes i support the g fund movement why
use the word defund why is the word
defront and it's like this is the word
that's coming from the street
many affluent suburb suburbs have
essentially already
begun pursuing a defunding of the police
in that
they fund schools not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department the minneapolis police
department is rotten
to the root defund the police does not
mean
abolish the police it means a dramatic
reduction
in the number of police in our poor
communities police are terrorizing black
and brown communities the evidence is
clear across the country
those are democrats sake okay those are
all democrats
all calling for defunding the police i
cannot find
video anywhere of any republicans
calling for defunding the police if you
think
that voting against your bailouts has
something to do with defunding the
police i mean you're again
you're gaslighting you're intentionally
lying to the american people
those are all democrats calling we want
to take
money away from the police at the end
there i think that was rafael warnock
the the senator from georgia and he's
basically saying we don't want to defund
them like get rid of them we just want
to take their money away
yeah and then you know what happens then
they don't have the backing putting
aside that you
defunding the police you take money away
you take resources away
from them well then there's probably
going to be less of them there will be
less patrols and everything else
he says oh well then they're going to go
into you know certain places
uh and economically depressed areas and
blah blah you know
when they do studies time after time
those people generally want more police
they want
less crime okay that's not to defend
every police action
everyone knows that i don't think i need
to say that at this point but when you
defund the police
and then you don't get the cities
backing the police
more crime comes in you guys all the
know the numbers new york
l.a san francisco portland seattle
everywhere
that there is a progressive mayor there
is an increasing crime right now there
is an increase
in homicide there's an increase in
homelessness there's an increase in drug
use do you
not think that these things are
connected they might
sort of be connected in some
way so saki you're a liar
you're a liar and i don't know why it's
left for me to call you a liar i wish
somebody else
would call you out in the mainstream but
i know you guys got those people in your
pockets because of say it with me
everybody
democrat privilege and speaking of
democrat privilege
you guys may remember barack obama he
was the president
uh for eight years before donald trump i
actually voted for obama twice i
completely regret it and you should
judge me accordingly but i was a
democrat i was a progressive i was a
lefty i suppose i was brainwashed at
some level
that's actually what my whole political
story is about the whole reason that so
many of you guys dig what i do because i
was honest about my political evolution
and i truly regret
voting for obama i think the country
would be in very different shape if
mccain had won
the first time around or even if romney
had won the second time around i have no
love for romney by the way
i think he's basically just a pet
republican but it probably would have
been better
than obama because obama loves this sort
of double speak
stuff too but right now
obama's been talking about
misinformation and
he doesn't like misinformation although
what he means by misinformation is stuff
that goes against the narrative
that he likes we've got some quotes here
from cnn
former president barack obama said
tuesday that the rise in misinformation
that led to the january
6th insurrection was apparent during his
administration
but the speed and prevalence with which
misinformation has increased in recent
years worries him
and should worry everyone the guardrails
i thought were in place around many of
our democratic institutions really
depend
on the two parties agreeing to those
ground rules
and that one of them right now doesn't
seem as committed to them
as in previous generations that worries
me obama said and i think
we should all be worried one of the
perpetrators of that not the originator
of it but
somebody who surfed that for their own
advantage was my successor donald trump
he said
and we saw how powerful the
constellation of conservative media
outlets talk radio and then ultimately
all of this gets turbocharged with
social media
how powerful that is now first off
there's so much here
because if you remember when obama
remember hope and change and everybody
was like
drinking ecstasy all day long when obama
was running the first time around and
everything was amazing and wonderful and
spectacular there were a
gillion i think that's a scientific term
i think i'm getting it right in the
amount
there were a gajillion articles written
how obama and the obama machine
had leveraged social media to get his
message out there and kids were on
instagram
and facebook campaigns and it was
exciting and new ways of sharing
information it was all wonderful
so it's wonderful when they do it then
when trump's supporters couple years
later
start sharing memes online and doing
funny videos of trump and putting his
head
on a dancing man and all of the other
stuff that happened then they're sharing
misinformation they're super charging
scary stuff okay so first off that's
just like a general part of it when they
do it
right it's good it's fun it's great we
write articles about how wonderful it is
a new generation figuring out how to
spread information
when the bad guys do it it's evil and we
must figure out a way to stop it okay
fine
um now of course what what obama really
is saying there
is that people are talking and they're
talking about things that he doesn't
like
right they're talking about how wokeness
is bad they're talking about how
critical race theory is bad
he doesn't want people to be able to
push back when the media pushes a hoax
the very fine people on both sides think
that was a complete hoax when they said
trump
said that because the sentence before
was i completely condemned the neo-nazis
but you never see that right
the the covington kids hoax as you know
brett kavanaugh is a racist jesse
smallett was
was attacked by white maga supporters
while eating a subway sandwich
the endless amount of stuff that we know
that they lie about if it wasn't
for conservative youtubers or
radio or whatever ability people still
have to be online to push back against
this
then all of their lies would in in
in sort of actuality they would be the
truth because there would be no way to
prove that they weren't true so it would
be the totality of everything
so thank god there is some counter thing
this is also the constant obsession
that these people have with getting fox
news off the air they
constantly are angry that people are
watching fox news and it's like
well why are people watching fox news
maybe some people agree with that maybe
some people would like a counter opinion
rather than just the blue and on stuff
that cnn and msnbc
are sharing with people so then what do
they do they start campaigns to get rid
of tucker's
advertisers to make sure that no
respectable person will go on fox news
or anything else
and ironically they then drive more
traffic to it because then fox news
is the outlier and i think one thing
that's that's good that's happening
right now
is conservative leaning people are
actually realizing that we got to build
our own stuff we got to fight back we
got to stop listening to these
hysterical children
and you know i was on a uh i was on a
youtube show in spain today uh don't
burn this book came out in spain a
couple weeks ago it's been number one
it's actually been the number one
um non-fiction book uh for quite some
time now since it came out
which is absolutely great and uh the
host was telling me how spain
is going through so many of the things
that we're going through that it just
sort of what america what happens in
america basically trickles everywhere
else two to three years later
and that actually is getting
supercharged by algorithms now so the
two to three year window that they used
to have as the buffer
is now getting smaller and smaller um
but we were talking about
sort of my political evolution and that
really i just started talking about all
of this stuff and that's what woke
people up and that
in many ways is what obama fears that's
what the machine fears right
like what do i tell you guys all the
time you don't have to agree with
everything i say here i actually welcome
you know in the rupen report community
sometimes
after the show people post you know dave
i didn't really agree with that or i
think you missed this point on this or
that or the other thing and it's like i
love that i love that exchange that
that's what it's all about and by the
way you know i like
correcting myself if we get something
wrong factual here i do it in the middle
of the show sometimes
i'm not perfect i'm one guy i got two
guys in here we're putting on something
that i think is
is slim and trim and worthy and that's
why you're watching
but that's what the machine doesn't want
right so when obama's talking about
misinformation
he doesn't really mean misinformation he
means the stuff
that he disagrees with because if
because let's put it this way
if you if you think or do you think
that if they had the power that they
would gladly
kick all of us off of youtube or gladly
take
fox news out make sure that tucker is
unable to communicate with people etc
etc and the answer to that is obviously
left
yes so so the question as always
for those of us that like plurality that
like freedom
that dig america that are excited to eat
hot dogs
on the 4th of july for those of us that
care about all that stuff
what do we do as these people keep
encroaching because we're not
encroaching on them
we just want to be left alone they're
encroaching on us and we got to figure
out how to build stuff
and and that's where my energies are
going to continue to be
and that's why i always appreciate the
support people because we're in this
thing together
part two of my interview with christian
angermeier really fascinating guy
it's a little bit of an offshoot from
what we normally do around here we talk
all about
psychedelics and depression and life
extension
and some really cool new tech stuff he's
a really fascinating guy thinks about
the world
in a very cool forward-thinking way in
the best sense of forward
thinking part two is up on youtube right
now the full episode of course is up ad
free at reubenreport.locals.com
and as i said at the top of the show
tomorrow's q a we're pre-taping it today
so that my guys can have a four-day
weekend so if you want to get a question
in
you got about an hour uh before we
select the questions
reubenreport.locals.com and then we're
not doing a roundtable on friday because
we are doing the four-day
weekend thing hope you have a great day
everybody mom happy birthday i'm gonna
facetime you in a little bit
and uh thanks for watching and and enjoy
the fourth everybody
that that well that america
it's great it's wonderful it's fantastic
we're gonna fight for it
i love you america happy birthday